Who are you?
Savitar.
The God of Speed.
Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie so we finally
get to see Savitar on the flash TV show but
there's a lot of confusion when he called
himself the God of speed so I was can explain
the difference between Godspeed in the comics
and Savitar and what the TV shows doing with
them.
So on the TV show you heard him call themselves
Savitar the God of speed in the comics the
reason that Savitar chose that name for himself
is because that's the Hindu god of motion.
So he thinks of himself as a God.
This Savitar also thinks of himself as a God
a lot of people saw him the way his costume
worked in just how bad as he was in thought
that he was talking about Godspeed now that's
not exactly what the TV show is doing.
But there are some similarities.
So Godspeed in rebirth is someone who is so
fast that he can be in two places at once.
See you can have like the normal person walking
around then you can have Godspeed running
around elsewhere murdering other speedsters.
So during flash rebirth.
There was the storyline where a speed force
storm comes and gives a whole bunch of people
powers a whole bunch of Rando people all over
the city so Barry has to deal with that he
has to train the ones that want to use their
powers yes to help the ones that don't want
their powers, but here is one of the biggest
differences about Godspeed he makes for a
much better TV and movie villain and comic
book Savitar did, so comic book Savitar really
just wanted to be one with the speed force
that was his only motivation so he would give
speed and take speed from people like he had
a speed cult that worship the speed force
with him.
So Savitar became this really weird trippy
religious story involving the speed force
but we know the big twist was is that Wally
West could give and take speed Savitar could
give intakes be it kind of change the way
we thought of the speed force itself.
It was during this Wally West era that they
actually first learned about the speed force
in itself.
So they were starting to use it is a way to
tell really interesting flash stories.
So people had different ways of harnessing
it Savitar is a villain as well as like the
stuff that was happening during flash rebirth
is just a way of kind of reimagining that
refreshing the way the comics treat the speed
force, so when the way the comic book Wally
West had like a block in his mind that stopped
him from going faster than Barry Allen for
a long time because eventually comic book
Wally got to be the fastest flash it was all
about this mental block that they'd erected
for themselves.
You know for whatever reason you do whatever
hangups they had it stop them from fully accessing
the speed force, so Godspeed Savitar back
during the Wally West run Hillhead like different
ways of harnessing the speed force.
It was just a way to tell really cool story
so in both of these characters were rolled
out they were supposed to be like these Uber
villains that were so crazy over the top powerful
that there is no way that Barry or Wally in
the case of Savitar would be able to defeat
them technically Barry Allen was around when
Savitar was around in the comics that was
until later.
But as with most big stories like this the
villains do something that provides the mechanism
for their downfall like they want too much
power and it just overwhelms them so that
kind of happened with Savitar.
It also kind of happened with Godspeed.
So the Savitar storyline was no pretty simple
arc where he basically just want all the speed
for himself eventually Wally finds a way to
give that to him.
You know the big twist and he winds up becoming
one with the speed force, so to speak like
that's what he seeks so Wally takes him faster
faster faster.
So you know you imagine someone like sticking
their finger and a light socket and then just
turning the juice way way up so they themselves
become pure energy, so that was the way that
Wally dealt with Savitar they brought him
back in the comics later in Barry took care
of them during the first flash rebirth in
a really funny way it was a twist that involve
the negative speed force which is something
that we haven't seen on the TV show yet.
So just bookmark that for future season but
is much Mark Wade Savitar stuff is there doing
this season like they're doing a mark way
character Savitar but there's a lot of Godspeed
flash rebirth stuff happening the way they
used him in that story in the way they took
him down so as you know in the comics.
Now they brought back Ginger Wally West like
the Wally West from Mark Wade era.
But there's also the African-American kid
flash Wally West.
So he ends up helping the flash in flash rebirth.
Take down Godspeed, but because the flash
does not kill as he says you know no more
were not doing this anymore he locks him up.
It was a much more emotional arc something
I think that would be much easier to adapt
for television like a much more fully formed
character arc for the villain instead of just
give me all the power are all kill you.
So what you'll probably see is that Savitar
on the TV show that there is a person underneath
that armor, but in the way that Godspeed in
a couple other people during the flash rebirth
comic manifest their costumes from the speed
force.
That's probably what you'll see him due to
he also has powers that people haven't seen
before an interesting twist on the speed force,
so fast that only people like the flash people
with the speed force can see him that's what
he looks really invisible here it is meant
to be super bad ass like oh he's so fast that
he's invisible, but when you're talking about
him with your friends and they ask you who
is the villain of the flash season three should
say Savitar not Godspeed but if they do ask
about Godspeed you can just say their borrowing
a lot of stuff from Godspeed was the TV show
tends to do like it did with zoom Hunter Solomon
and Jay Garrick a kind of blend a lot of stuff
but zoom in the comics is Hunter Solomon zoom
on the TV show was Hunter Solomon.
So that's why think that Savitar will still
be Savitar from the comics but their borrowing
a lot of stuff from Godspeed in the comics
you like e-forms's costume out of the speed
force he does crazy things that no flash is
been able to do before even the reverse flash
who supposedly knows more about the speed
force than anybody else the whole reason that
is called Prof. zoom in the comics is because
he is a professor of flash and speed force
studies in the 25th century like they have
a school dedicated to studying the flash in
the speed force.
He eventually became one of the instructors
the real twist of the TV show in this was
also evident during the Godspeed run is that
Barry kind of creates his own problems.
So you know whatever's going on with Savitar
with Doctor alchemy that happened because
of flashpoint, because of something Barry
did when he was being selfish trying to save
his parents, even though it meant changing
the timeline.
So in the comics.
Godspeed was kind of a consequence of the
stuff that Barry was not willing to do with
a very flashpoint type twist Godspeed wanted
the flash to go back in time and change the
past.
So that his brother's murder would not go
free like Barry's parents were murdered he
try to go back in time and change that causes
flashpoint is a huge nightmare.
So he starts to learn the lesson that there
are some things that you cannot change that
or some bad things that happened to you just
have to learn to accept Godspeed of course
is a brand-new speedster with a huge axe to
grind against his brother's murder has not
learned this lesson yet.
So the big question of what would you do if
you were given the powers of the flash would
you be a hero or would you start crossing
the line being judged, jury executioner, so
I will say in the comics the Godspeed arc
was a much better character arc.
But I think that you know Savitar which is
like a really interesting story for the time
that it was published that as with all things
the way they write the speed force in the
comics of falls over time so they just try
to do new interesting things with it sometimes
it's cool sometimes it doesn't work out, but
if you want to read along in flash rebirth
is like one of the best new comics like your
flash fan and you want to read the comics
I just recommend you start with flash rebirth.
Don't worry about reading the old stuff the
TV shows only doing a little bit of stuff
from that Savitar run and I'll point out all
the comic book stuff when they do it on the
TV show but as with Godspeed's end in the
comics of the way they take him down with
the help of kid flash Wally West I think they'll
also try to do something similar on the TV
show because now TV show Wally West is getting
his powers, but the question is is what is
he gonna do with those powers.
So I think you know because the TV show wants
a more hopeful spin he will try to help but
a big part of his arc.
This season is in learning to be a hero but
he doesn't get his powers and just automatically
learn everything that he needs to learn overnight
he has to learn a lot of the same lessons
that Barry learned the first couple of seasons
and then there's the idea that Barry has only
been the flash for little while himself so
he's probably not the best teacher not as
good as say Jay Garrick so hopefully the TV
show bring back Jay Garrick pretty soon and
you can drop some knowledge bombs on them
cracked cup style like he gave Barry that
speech look, kid, you can go back in time
every time you want to.
You crack the very fabric of reality.
Every time you try to play God.
So whole bunch of crazy stuff happening tonight
is the killer Frost episodes I'll probably
end up doing like a killer Frost video later
this week to just because she's a really interesting
character from the comics.
I can't wait to see what they do with her
on the TV show is going to continue to be
a big part of the show so don't worry you
do whatever ends up happening with her shall
still be on the show.
I think the just try to tell a really interesting
Caitlin arc so be sure to subscribe to get
that video will post it after the episode
airs tonight and there is a new round of the
DC giveaway that's going on right now all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video I'll go
ahead and announce the winner when I post
that flash video tonight, but what can happen
is because Arrow and legends of tomorrow on
break him to take the opportunity to do a
couple bonus videos notice restart the giveaway
as I post new DC videos.
So just look out for that stuff.
And if you do want me to start doing more
comic book videos to go along with some of
the TV and movie stuff that I'm doing then
let me know in the comments feel free to make
suggestions while you guys wait for that to
post you can click here to learn all about
the history of Cyborg Superman in the comics,
what the TV shows doing with him and click
here for my Killer Frost Flash trailer thank
you so much watching everybody high five I'll
see you guys tonight!